Hey everyone, hope you're having an amazing day, it's mark Wiens
I'm in Bali, Indonesia and one of the best places you can come for a night market of traditional
Balinese indonesian street food is called "Pasar Senggol" which is in Gianyar, so we just arrived this evening
They're just opening up. There's a lot of street food to choose from here, and we're gonna start eating. I'm hungry
There's an
amazing choice of Balinese food to choose from but there's no better way to start than with babi guling which is one of the
Most famous of all Balinese dishes, it's the roasted pig and they have the entire pig sitting up front there
Yeah, I don't know if there's anything better than sitting with your your face to the to the snout
Okay, thank you
Alright babi guling is served
Terima kasih
This is such a cool warung little stalls they have, they're all
Bar counter chefs counter seated they have they have all the food laid out, and you just sit down they have
Seats around the stall and I got a classic plate of babi guling complete with everything
There's the the roast pig you get a little portion of the skin and then some of the meat down there some of the sausage
another type of sausage and then some crunchy pork cracklings, and then some other sambal all over a
Little scoop of rice, okay, let's get started and dissect this plate. Oh, yeah, so you lift up look at that skin
It's so crispy. And
You can see you can just hear your fork that hardness, and you can just see it glistening and then under here
They have some of the chopped up pork and then some sambal mixed in here
Oh, and I think that's some lawar as well. I got coconut long bean salad
Hmm oh, yeah
Hmm. Oh the sambal in there the meat is really nice and tender and then I got some of that some of that relish
just that lawar you can taste the coconut in there you can taste the
the coconut and the long beans
Yeah
That's the bite you crave when you eat babi guling that crunchy skin, okay, let's try some of that sausage there
I know that dark one it's the blood sausage
But I'm not sure what the the white one is that definitely looks like a an intestine rich sausage
I think that might be egg sausage sort of has like a spongy egg spring to it.
Oh
I really, love the pork cracklin here cuz they're so
So like airy they're like just bubbles of crispiness what truly makes babi guling so
Fabulous is the different mixture of all the ingredients, so you not only have the skin in the pork
But you also have all sorts of different
textural and flavorful
Excitements including the sambal, the lawar, the satay, the the pork crackling
All sorts of all sorts of different things go into a plate of babi guling
Okay time for that blood sausage
Oh, Wow!
It sort of just squeezes like a like a tub of toothpaste oh
Okay, I guess you can't cut that in half. You need to just eat it all in one bite
That's a little on the smooth like chocolaty side for me. How are you? Hello
Okay babi guling is complete. That was a delicious plate of food. That was a real street food version
It was it was very good
But it was a little it served a little bit cold so I think it would have been better if it was really like piping
Hot and a little fresher, but really hot
But still it was it was very tasty and that sambal was fantastic along with the crispy pork
You'll find quite a few snack little dessert stalls and they're pretty busy right now
But they have a bunch of desserts set up in the back and then they package everything into little little
Plastic little boxes, and then you can get them
I think every box is just one thousand rupiah's so we got a couple boxes to try. What's the name of this one?
"Klepon"
There's a there's a staple and you don't want to eat this staple okay, and these are little
Bite sized, Would you like one?
All right, and so you can see that there's coconut all around the outside of this, and it feels well
It feels very squishy in your fingers
It's really surprising you're not expecting that! As soon as you bite down
It's really really pillowy and soft, but as soon as you bite down
like a an explosion of
Sweet syrup
Comes into your mouth
Three dimensions to it the surf on the inside, which I think is palm sugar, the gooey rice cake and then
The fresh coconut on the outside, okay?
Make sure you you keep track of those staples so that you don't take a bite of a staple
Which would be a pretty bad idea
Put some coconut on top and you can see these are kind of like.. Oh wow they're kind of like dense
This is okay, you've got a little you've got a little packet here of palm sugar. Well. Thank you Made. A
little packet of palm sugar
So you put some on the top yeah?
As much as you want okay?
Depending how much of a sweet tooth you have you can add as much of the palm sugar
Syrup as much as you like how much do you want, Made? Oh?
That much or more? I love sweet one. Okay, this one is for you
Made you have that one, I'll..
You want more coconut? No. Okay, I'll add some more coconut
Well, that's like a that feels like kind of like a blob of extra cooked noodles that start to stick together
That kind of tastes like a very very well cooked dough or like boiled dough, kind of
They have quite a few stalls on this side
But then they also have a lot of street food stalls on the other side
So we're crossing over the street now to the other stalls
It's time for another plate of food
We have arrived at the next stall and this is a plate of food that looks absolutely incredible
And look at my my background
You've got some grilled chicken
They have some ayam tutu which is one of the most common one of the most famous Balinese dishes
It's a it's a chicken which is just for the plates of food that they are serving up as well as to the
testament of how busy this place is
This is a must eat that we had to stop here immediately
We just ordered the nasi campur
Which is gonna be a plate that includes a little bit of everything, a mix, campur means a mix
This is an impressive plate of food. I can't wait till mine comes
I'm just I'm just eyeing it in awe I'm beginning with a cup of iced tea. Oh
Good classic this is my drink of choice at Warungs just black tea with no
Sugar and just iced. It's very refreshing and then before your main plate of rice comes they serve you a soup
There's some meat in here. Oh here, it arrives
Oh, that's a beautiful plate of food. This is absolutely
Insanely beautiful, and I love how they've just piled everything on top of the rice
You've got that the scoop of rice on the bottom
And then they have some some of the grilled chickens some of the ayam tutu and
Then there's some lawar down there. There are some peanuts some roasted peanuts there, are there's half an egg. There's some cucumber
There's two different types of sambal
There's a like a red sauce sambal and then there's a sambal matah
Which is the there's some shallots in there and chilies, and I think coconut oil that is five-star gourmet right there?
Oh, that's gorgeous
This is a plate of food that makes me happy before even taking my first bite
And you can kind of reach in with your fingers and grab a little bit you can add some peanuts
You can add some lawar and some of the chicken and just mix it with the rice, and then take your first bite
Wow
Oh that is
insane
Oh the texture of that drumstick is unbelievably creamy
Oh, that's so good and then mix with that sambal the shallots in there the chilies oh
Man, I got some crunch from those salty peanuts. That's insane. Oh that is that is award-winning
The texture of that chicken
Unbelievably good. I love it with both of the sambals. You've got that red. Sambal. Which is a little more
Sweet, and then the the shallots sambal which is just pure salty and kind of oily and just packed of flavor
It's so good, this is an amazing meal
Man I love it okay now moving unto the egg
Well the egg has a little bit of a bounce to it, this is such a properly good mixture of flavors and combinations
Okay next up. I'll try the soup here, and there's a banana trunk in here as well as some kind of meat
I think chicken bones
Yeah, that taste like chicken broth and there might be some turmeric in there to make it yellow as well
That's really got to to complement the whole meal
Wow that was
Incredibly good. That was one of the better single plates of food that I've had in Bali. I loved that mixture the flavors were delicious
Really fresh really vibrant and not to mention pretty that was, that was like gourmet
Placing and decoration
There are a lot of things to eat, but there's a lot of repetitions, so there's a lot of stalls selling the same dishes
So there's actually not not a huge huge variety, but there's there's still a lot to to try and sample.
We stopped next for a dish called tipat cantok
And it looks very similar to me to gado-gado indonesian gado-gado
And she she made the whole thing right before me
I watched her make it she first added in to the big giant stone mortar and pestle
But the flat one she added some peanuts
But it almost looks good kind of like peanut brittle and that she added in a couple
Chillies some garlic and that she mashed that up with the masher
And then she added in some water to make a sauce consume that entire
Stone base was just covered in sauce and then she added in that ketupat which are rice cakes which are steamed in
Palm leaves and then she chopped that up into the into the the
peanut sauce and then she added in a handful of
I think they're baby bean sprouts, and then finally she
Added in some lime some topping with some crispy onions crispy shallots
And then finally drizzled it in some I think that's kecap manis
Which is the sweet soy sauce so this is a very interesting dish. She made it all fresh and
This is a it's pretty cool
I'm digging in and you can see the big chunks of rice cake you can see oh, there's some cabbage in here, too
And if she just coated everything evenly in that sauce
Hmm yeah truly peanutty it has that, that real contrast
It's both salty and sweet, but nothing overpowering each other
You've got the rice cake which is really soft, and then you've got the slightly blanched bean sprouts and cabbage which
Give it a different texture as well. Oh, and I forgot to mention. They served in on the classic ajinomoto plate
It's kind of like a salad mixture, but then it's it's very dense it's very filling because of those those rice cakes in there
But I like I like the mix that she made. It's a little bit spicy you can taste the garlic in there and then
It really is both both sweet and salty at the same time with that nice peanut flavor
And I'm having another cup of iced tea
My beverage of choice oh man, this is one of those straws that when you when you suck it it closes
So it's kind of kind of got a drip kind of slowly
Oh thank you, Ying
They're really nice
especially the
Elderly auntie who made that she's really she's really an expert. How she I loved watching her make that I love watching
Things that are made like that when they especially with a mortar and pestle
And how they squish the ingredients and just pound everything out
But that was to me that was very similar in taste to gado-gado, but with a little bit of a different ingredient
Component makeup within the market you will find quite a few stalls serving snack which is called Serombotan
And it's a it's again. It's a mixture of many different
Components, and she has all the different things laying out. There's some bean sprouts. There's some water spinach
I think some long beans there's some green banana slices
There's some soy beans and then some peanuts, and then she mixes everything into a paper cone, and then she added in some spicy
coconut plus some peanut sauce and some sambal
Terima kasih oh it's a spoon, oh terima kasih
It looks pretty good that it's actually all just vegetables and then just that that sauce different sauces and so I think you can just
kind of this is kind of like a
boiled vegetable snack
Oh
I
Really like that mm-hmm. That's
Delicious I was expecting it to be more, sweet, but it's not sweet at all
I thought it was gonna taste exactly like it looks, but it's actually better than it looks. It's really good. The vegetables are nice and
Crisp, and then you've got the crunchy soybeans and crunchy nuts in there, and then what really comes through is that that coconut?
man that coconut is awesome and
the green banana in there
That's a that's a wonderful mixture
I really like it and you kind of got a scoop towards the bottom because in all that sauce starts to go to the bottom
Man I'm impressed by how good this one is
That's awesome and it's really really healthy as well
Just all vegetables and that coconut and peanut and on that note I think we're gonna wrap up this tour of Pasar Senggol
this is a
Great little market what I like about it. Is that it's very
Relaxed it's very laid-back
You can come here and just kind of stroll around and you can go from stall to stall and try you can get snacks both
Snacks and whole plates of food, so thank you very much for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
I'd love to hear from you in the comments section below
And if you're not already subscribed click subscribe now for lots more food and travel videos goodnight from the night market
And I'll see you on the next video. Thanks again for watching